اسعد الله مسائكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض والتي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخباره ملفات السعوديه
والخليج هذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
وزير الطاقه السعوديه يقول ان التطورات
العالميه اثبت صحه قرار مجموعه اوبك بلس
الاقتصاد السعودي ينمو بنحو تسعه في المئه
خلال الربع الثالث محققا افضل اداء ربعي
له منذ 13 عاما
متحدث الارصاد السعوديه يحذر من حاله
مطريه من متوسطه الى غزيره على محافظه جده
ابتداء من مساء اليوم
ومن ملفات المتنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
النيابه العامه في السعوديه تعلن عن صدور
احكام بالسجن لعشرين عاما ضد خمسه متهمين
بغسل الاموال
العربيه تتجول في منطقه ذاكروفس وترصده
تجربه الزائرين في منطقه المطاعم الفاخره
حياكم الله خير الجلسه الثانيه من ملتقى
ميزانيه السعوديه والتي عقدت في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض اكد وزير طاقه السعوديه
الامير عبد العزيز بن سلمان حرصه على
مشاركه كل اعضاء تحالف في اوبك بلس في صنع
القرار مضيفا ان التطورات العالميه
الاخيره اثباتات ان المجموعه تتخذت القرار
الصحيح
العمل الجماعي يتوجب يستوجب التوافق
ولذلك من الاساس كنت مازلت وسوف ابقى مصر
على انه اعطاء كل دوله من دول اوبك بلس
سواء كان حجم صغير او كبير حقها في ان
تمارس حقها بانها تكون صاحبه القرار وجزء
من منظومه القرار
وهذا الحقيقه عنه كثيرا في البدايه وحتى
الان في ان همم
نعزز من الثقه الداخليه في نفس المنظومه
نفسها بيننا كدول وبين المشاركين
هذا واضح وزير الطاقه
منظور اقتصاديا بعيد عن الشان السياسي
مضيفا انها حريصه على الحد من تقلبات
الاسواق ولديها برامج ورؤيه ومستهدفات
للحفاظ على سوق الطاقه كل هذه
اللي ابتدات
من شهر اغسطس
ودي للمتابعين يراجعون تصريح سويته انا 23
اغسطس
واكد في على بعض الاوامر الامور الاساسيه
في عمل اوبك بلس
واكد في انه المنظومه سوف تستمر في اداء
عملها وفقا
لمنظورها الاقتصادي فقط
وما قامت به وسوف تقوم به في عمليه اعاده
استقال الاسواق اخذ من الاعتبار المعطيات
الان
الانيه
وما هو متصور من قبل بلاس
في لقاء خاص مع العربيه
فيصل ابراهيم ان نمو الاقتصاديه المتوقع
لهذا العام يصلوا الى 8 ونصف في المئه
مضيفا ان نمو الانشطه غير النفطيه هو
الاسرع خلال 11 عاما الماضيه
يصل الى 8:30 هذا العام حتى نهايه الربع
الثالث كان 10.2 ممكن يكون اكثر من ذلك
النمو الانشطه غير النفطي وهذا اهم شيء
نتبعه همم في الربع الثاني كان 8 فاصل
اثنين في الربع الثالث كان تقريبا سته حتى
نهايه الربع الثالث من بدايه سنه فاصل 5.9
وهو من اسرع همم
همم يعني معدلات النمو في الانشطه غير
النفطيه في 11 12 سنه الماضي يعني همم
اهتمامنا مستقبلا هو استمرار نمو الانشطه
غير النفطيه لان ذلك دليل على استقلالنا
نوعا ما عن الاعتماد على النفط ودليل على
احدى ادله همم النجاح في تنويع الاقتصاد
وخلال ملتقى الميزانيه كده وزير الشؤون
البلديه والقرويه والاسكان ماجد الحقيل
انا نسب التملك تسير كما هو مخطط لها
والوزاره تهدف لزيادتها العمل المقبل
موضحا بانه تم توفيره اكثر من 30,000 وحده
سكنيه للاسر الى اكثر حاجه وسيتم وضخه
اكثر من 300,000 وحده سكنيه جديده في
مختلف مدن السعوديه خاصه المناطق التي
شهدت ارتفاعا في الاسعار
استهدف ان شاء الله العام القادم لنقدم
مليون تقريبا نزيد واحد بالمئه بالنسبه
للتملك ايضا بدانا بدعم من السيد خادم
الحرمين مسموع العهده بدعم وزاره الاسكان
باراضي في المناطق التي تشهد ارتفاع اسعار
اكثر من ما هو يعني مقدره الشرائيه
للمواطنين وسيتم ضخ اكثر من 300,000 ان
شاء الله على اغلب مدن المملكه ولكن
التركيز الاكبر هيكون في المناطق اللي
شهدت ارتفاعات سعريه يعني همم اتعبت
المواطن ونبغى نرجع للمستوى الطبيعي اللي
احنا نستهدف ان شاء الله في المرحله
القادمه ايضا فيما يخص طبعا الاسر الاشد
حاجه في الاسكان الحمد لله تقريبا
بالتعاون مع اكثر من 350 جمعيه استطعنا ضخ
اكثر من 30,000 وحده سكنيه لليسر لشد حاجه
مستمرين بهذا النهج اللي نصل الى 70,000
وحده سكنيه ان شاء الله هذا العام والعام
المقبل ان شاء الله
هذا واضح وزير ماليه السعوديه محمد
الجدعان الوصول الاقتصادي لمرحله الصفريه
في العجز وتسجيل الفائض جاء نتيجه
الاستراتيجيه تخطيط استمرت على مدى ثلاث
سنوات واكثر موضحا ان الاستراتيجيه
انتهجها عدد من القطاعات على مدى عشر
سنوات قادمه
اعتمادك على ايراد ياتي من
مصدر متذبذب
خطير جدا
وهو ما ادى الى مساله الحجوزات السابقه
الان وصلنا الى مرحله
انتقل من مرحله برنامج التوازن المالي الى
برنامج الاستعلام الماليه اللي يخطط على
من سنوات
بعد القطاعات الان فيها خطط لمده عشر
سنوات
صرنا نتفق معهم على مدى عشر سنوات كيف
بيكون الانفاق
[موسيقى]
حضارات بيناتهم الهيئه العامه للاحصائي في
السعوديه ارتفاع الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
الحقيقي خلال الربع الثالث من هذا العام
بنسبه
8.8% مقارنه بالربع المماثل من عام 2021
تفاصيل اكثر مع زميله العنود العبد
تلفون
لكن المشترك هو النمو المتوالي الذي شهده
الاقتصاد السعودي في عام 20 22 حيث اعلنت
الهيئه العامه للاحصاء تسجيل النمو في
الناتج المحليه الاجمالي بما يقارب تسعه
في المئه في الربع الثالث من العام الجاري
مقارنه بالرابعه ثالث من العام الماضي هذا
الارتفاع جاء مدعوما بارتفاع الانشطه
النفسيه في اكثر من 14% اضافه الى الانشطه
غير النفطيه التي سجلت نمو رباعيا بسته في
المئه واخيرا ارتفاع الانشطه الحكوميه
بنسبه النمو بلغت اثنين ونصف في المئه
مشاهدينا فيما يخص الناتج المحليه
الاجمالي تحديدا فقد تجاوز الفا من زياره
ريال بالاسعار الجاريه في الربع الثالث من
العام
وشمالا كافه الانشطه الاقتصاديه التي سجلت
نموا على اساسا سنويا جاء في مقدمتها نشاط
الزيت والغاز بالنسبه اقتربت
15% ثم صناعات التحويليه باحد 10% وفي
المرتبه الثالثه انشطه النقل والتخزين
بينما جاءت او جاء العقار في المرتبات
الاقل بين الانشطه الاقتصاديه الانشطه غير
النفطيه في السعوديه مشاهدينا لاعبه دورا
رئيسيا في تنويع مصادر نمو الاقتصاد
بوثيره تعد الاسرع منذ 12 سنه هذا واوضح
الاحصاء السعوديه ايضا ان الوالدات ارتفعت
بمعدل بلغ نحو واحد وثلاثين في المئه في
20 22 ونحو 20% من النمو حققته تجاره
الصادره السعوديه خلال الفتره ذاتها
وانضم الينا هنا في الاستديو الكاتب
والبحث الاقتصادي الدكتور علي الحازمي
الدكتور الرابع من الرياض
خلال هذا العام كل ربع يرتفع اكثر فاكثر
حتى وصلنا الى الربع الثالث
8.8 عندما نقارنه ب 2021 لماذا هنا اعتقد
الارتفاعات هي صناعه في هذا العام ولكن
اذا تتبع لها تاريخيا منذ الربع الثاني من
العام 20 21 تقريبا نحن في الربع السادس
من الارتفاعات اه انا اعتقد هو يتوافق مع
التوقعات المملكه يتوافق مع
الخطه الاستراتيجيه والتحولات
الاستراتيجيه التي تعيشها المملكه ما يحدث
حقيقه الانشطه النفطيه ربما لعبت دور بشكل
كبير ارتفاع اسعار النفط نعم لعب دور كبير
وده شهاده ان هذا الربع فقط تقريبا
الانشطه النفطيه زائدا همم نتحدث عن
الانفاق او الانشطه الحكوميه شكلت تقريبا
5% من
اجمالي الناتجه المحلي الذي يصل يتجاوز
التريليون ريال همم انا انا اعتقد بان
التحولات الهيكليه التي او التغييرات
الهيكليه في الاقتصاد السعودي لعبت دور
محوري ومهم في هذه في هذه الارقام منذ
بدايه العام 20 22 وصناع القرار في
المملكه يتحدثون عن هذا النمو كان هناك مد
وجذب في المنظمات الدوليه بداوا تقريبا من
4.5% كانوا اقتصادي اليوم خلصنا الى هذا
الربع الى 8.8% في المجمل ما سيكون عليها
هذا العام يصل الى مستويات الثمانيه فاصله
5% كما اوضح معالي الوزير الجدعان هذا همم
بنهايه العام تتحدث انه حيوصل للمجموع
كاملا ثمانيه فاصله همم 5% وهذا بالنسبه
للسعوديه عندما نتحدى التاريخيه منذ
تقريبا ثلاثه عشر عاما لم تتحقق هذه
الارقام همم ايش ممكن نتوقع الناتج المحلي
قيمه الناتج المحلي كم ستصبح في نهايه هذا
العاميه عليه تجاوز الترلي والريال
ترليون دولار نعم حقيقه هذا هو
الفيصل في هذه السنه كنا نتحدث في بدايه
السنه بان هذه السنه ستكون الناتج المحلي
تريليوني شككت بعض المنظمات الدوليه اتت
الارقام حقيقه مؤكدا انا اعتقد سنصل الى
مستويات الثلاثه فاصله تسعه تريليون وهذا
رقم كبير ويتوافق حقيقيتا مع التوجهات من
رؤيه المملكه 2030 متى تنزل ثلاثه فاصل
تسعه اه ريال ريال يعني سنصل الان في هذا
العام ثلاثه فاصل تسعه وبيعام 20 23 ستكون
ثلاثه فاصله تقريبا سته وثلاثه فاصله همم
ثمانيه في حلول عام حتى ما توقعات انه
العمل القادم لن يكون يعني عاما همم
اقتصادي همم
نقول باسما سيكون هناك بالحديث عن الركود
اقتصادي لحديث عن الكاسات الحديث عن يعني
الربع الاول والربع ثاني ستكون سنوات
اقتصاديه همم مصاحبه ليس على يعني معنى
لكن على لسان كثير من المحللين الخبراء
الاقتصاديين ايضا كذلك هذه كيف ممكن تاثر
على هذا النمو السريع تحدث عن همم تقريبا
الربع السادس كما ذكرت وامامنا من الربع
السابع وثمن لكن سيحدث انا اعتقد العام
نعم حاله عدم اليقين التي تهيمين على
المشهد الاقتصادي هي ليست والدته اللحظه
منذ بدايه العام 20 22 وكان حقيقه منظمات
الدوليه تتحدث بان الاقتصاد العالمي لايسر
بشكل جيد كانت هناك توقعات لنمو الاقتصاد
العالم وبعد ذلك خفضت المنظمات العالميه
هذه الارقام نعم حاله عدم اليقين تسيطر
على المشهد حاله الاغلاقات الصين محرك مهم
واستراتيجي لنمو العالمي كان هناك منطلق
زيرو كورونا او زيرو كوفيد اغلاقات الان
نوعا ما هناك انفراجات نتحدث الاوضاع
الاوروبيه نعم كيف تنعكس علينا احنا يعني
احنا ما نبي نتحدث عن اللي صاير في همم
بصينا واللي في اوروبا احنا اكيد جزء طبعا
عملنا انعكاسه بالنسبه همم بالنسبه لنا
كيف ممكن يؤثر على الناتج المحلي على
الاقتصاد ايضا السعودي على ديموميه الحركه
على جذب الاستثمار وغيرها طبعا اذا تحدثت
عن الناتج المحليه ان احنا نتحدث عن
الانشطه او ان اسعار النفط وهي محرك اساسي
في الناتج المحلي عندما نقول حاله عدم
اليقين هذا يعني بانه انخفاض الطلب على
اسعار النفط او اا مستقبلا وهذه من شانها
ان تؤثر على الناتج المحلي الاجمالي ولكن
اعتقد بان المراجعات الدوليه همم الدوريه
المنظمه واستشراف المستقبل من حيث زياده
الانتاج وخفض الانتاج المملكه حقيقه نعم
تم تخفيض اثنين مليون برميل من الانتاج
ولكن هناك مراجعات دولي همم دوري الان
نتحدث عن اسعار النفطه في مستويات
الثمانين دولار وهي ارقام جيده ولكن اعتقد
بان الان نعم حاله عدم اليقين في المشهد
العالمي تؤثر على قرارات
من زياده وانخفاض وعندما كان الاجتماع في
اربعه من ديسمبر تحدث همم سمو الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان بقى قال بان سنستمر في
المرحله الرابعه والمراجعات كما هي لذلك
هذا هو يؤثر حقيقه الدول النفطيه يؤثر
عليها مثل هذه المراجعات بشكل كبير وزياده
الانتاج او خفض الانتاج النفطي ممتاز احنا
نتحدث عن افضل اداء فصلي في 13 عاما
والحديث عن التحولات الاقتصاديه في
السعوديه الحديث كذلك عن الاصلاحات ايضا
همم الحديث ايضا حتى عن اليوم ميزانيه همم
سعوديه قويه في الميزانيه كذلك كان متوقعا
او اكثر من ما كان متوقعا فبالتالي اتحدث
عن الاداء الفصل نهايه العام هل سيكون
اكثر مما تن- نتوقع ام لا التوقعات ربما
ستكون اقرب الى ان ثمانيه فاصله خمسه مثل
هذا الكلام يعني اعتقد بان انا هاعرف انا
على نهايه العام لم يتبقى تقريبا الا 15
يوم اعلنت حقيقه الميزانيه لهذا العام
بارقام حقيقيه كانت الارادات النفطيه وصلت
الى مستويات 812 مليار ايرادات غير نفطيه
كانت في يوميات 300 تقريبا و52 مليار في
المجمل انا اعتقد بان هذا العام قد
انتهينا وخرجت ارقام واكد لك بانها بنسبه
99% حقيقيه الرهان هو على العام القادم
حتى على مستوى الفوائد همم هذه العام
تتحدثين عن فائض 102 مليار السنه القادمه
بحقيقه هناك تحفظ نوعا ما بسبب الاوضاع
العالميه التي تحدث عن فائض ربما يصل فقط
الى مستويات ال16 مليار ريال لذلك انا
اعتقد حتى عندما عملت ميزانيه العامه 2023
كان هناك نظرا لاوضاع العالميه ونعم هي
نظره ربما لا تكون تفاؤليه بشكل كبير ولكن
على الاقل نحن داخل المناطق الايجابيه او
البوستاتف في النمو الاقتصادي على المجمل
التي تتحدثين على اقوى 20 اقتصاد في
العالم هناك فرق كبير ما بين المملكه وما
بين الدوله التي لها لذلك احنا انا اعتقد
في العالم القادمه يتحدث عن ثلاثه فاصله
سته في المئه في النمو كم همم في المجمل
انا اعتقد من وجهه نظري هو ارقام فض نوعا
ربما نحقق ارقام افضل من هذا المستقبل على
كل هذه التفاصيل كل هذه المعلومات مع
تمنياتنا طبعا بنكون العام القادم هو عامل
اقتصادي جيد باسم يخالف كل التوقعات ان
شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور علي
الحازمي الباحث والكاتب الاقتصادي
رابع مستمره فيها
الارصاد السعوديه تتحذر من حاله البطاريه
من متوسطه الى غزيره على محافظه جده
ابتداء من مساء اليوم
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنا وزير الحج
والعمره السعوديه توفيق الربيعه خلال
مؤتمر الصحفي مع نظيره التركي علي ارباش
الغاء الاجراءات الصحيه الخاصه بلقاح
فيروس كورونا للمعتمرين القادمين من تركيا
في اطار التسهيلات التي تقدمها السعوديه
للقادمين لاداء العمره والزياره اوضح
الربيعه ان المعتمرين الاتراك مستثنينه من
اي اشتراطات تتعلق بتحديد العمر مؤكدا
ترحيب السعوديه بالمعتمرين دون حد لاعداد
القادمين مع اتاحات اداء العمره للحاصلين
على كافه انواع التاشيرات من جميع انحاء
دول العالم
حضر المركز الوطني للارصاد في السعوديه من
حاله مطريه على محافظه جده من متوسطه الى
غزيره ابتداء من مساء اليوم ياتي تحذير
المركز الوطني للتزامل مع حاله المطريه
وانخفاض في درجات الحراره على معظم
المناطق والتي سجلت ادناها على محافظه
الطيف شمال السعوديه عندنا درجه حراره بست
درجات مئويه اللي هي القريات والمجموعه
بسبع درجات ثم الرياض وحائل بثمانيه درجات
مئويه
من جده ينضم الينا متحدث باسم مركز الوطني
للارصاد حسين القحطاني سيد حسين مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض اول انا
اولا هل لك ان توجد وتوصف لنا هذه الحاله
الجويه المطريه التي ستمر بها مدينه جده
هذا اليوم ومحافه جدا
[ضحك]
هذه الليله وتكون شد بمشيئه الله في
الفترات الصباحيه ليوم الاثنين حقيقا
المؤشرات تشير الى امطار ما بين متوسطه
الى غزيره مصحوبه برياح نشطه واتربه مثاره
وتدني للرؤيه احتماليه تساقط البرض على
المناطق المتاثره لمنطقه مكه المكرمه منها
العاصمه المقدسه جدا رابقه الطائف الجموم
الكامل وايضا خلال والليز والجنفذه واضم
وميثان هذه اغلب المناطق المتاثره في
منطقه مكه المكرمه هذه الليله وطبعها ان
شاء الله طيب المستويات المتوقعه سيد حسين
لهذه الامطار يعني احنا همم شفنا الحاله
المطريه اللي مرت فيها محافظه جده تحديدا
خلال الشهر الماضي كانت حاله غير مسبوقه
يعني وصلت فيها تقريبا الى 179 او 182 ملم
من يعني مياه الامطار هذه المره هل
تتوقعون ذات الحاله ذات الغزاره او شيء
مختلف
هذه الحاله قد تكون غزيره ولكنها قد لا
تقوم بمعدلات الامطار التي هطلت على جده
في الحاله الماضيه لكن التقرير الصادر من
المركز الوطني اقصاد ايضا يشير الى السيول
الناتجه عن هذه الحالات خاصه كل ما اتجهنا
جنوبا لمنطقه مكه المكرمه
المتقدم الى تحذير على بعض اجزاء خاصه
بحرا ومن المتوقع استمرار حاله التحذير
على هذه المناطق خلال فتره هذه الليله
وسيقوم المركز ايضا بمراقبه الحاله
واستاره التنبيهات والتحذيرات اللازمه
احيان المناطق المتاثره سواء منطقه مكه
المكرمه او المناطق الاخرى المشموله في
هذه الحاله
بتعليق مثلا همم الدراسه غدا او الموظفين
ايضا كذلك كذلك الجهات المعنيه هل بدات
تنسيق معهم منذ وقت همم مبكر الامور هذه
مهمه نعرف عنها السيد حسين نعم صحيح حقيقه
المركز الوطني ارصاد يعمل وفقاليه متبعه
مع الجهاز ذات العلاقه التي تتعامل مباشره
مع الظواهر الجويه يتم التمرير المعلومات
منذ وقت مبكر وتسهيل مهمه هذه الجهات في
اتخاذ اجراءاتها ميدانيه مع هذه الحاله
هناك تنسيق مع معظم هذه الجهات سواء
التعليم او الجهات الاخرى لاتخاذ القرارات
المناسبه في مثل هذه الحالات
او يعني صار في حديث مع التعليم بتعليق
الدراسه غدا او امكانيه تعليق الدراسه يوم
غدا في جده او مكه وزاره التعليم اي
معلومات اضافيه متعلقه بالحاله او شرح
معلومات اخرى يقوم المركز بذلك بشكل مباشر
والمركز يعمل على مدى ال 24 ساعه لتسهيل
مهمه الجهات في هذا النظام يعني اعلم انه
في اليه عمل وغيره لكن هل طلب منكم من
وزاره التعليم انه تقدموا لهم توصيات او
سؤال عن الحاله يوم همم غدا
في هذا الجانب ومنها وزاره التعليم لتسهيل
مهمه اتخاذ القرارات المناسبه في مثل هذه
الحالات بالنسبه للمناطق الاخرى في
السعوديه رياض يعني مرت في همم حاله مطريه
ربما اليومين الماضيين او ثلاثه ايام
الماضيه هل ستستمر هذه الحاله هل ستعود
مره اخرى كم ستستمر كذلك وباقي المناطق
السعوديه لكن بتحديث الرياضه اول
نعم هذه الحاله ايضا تؤثر على عدد من
مناطق المملكه من المدينه المنوره والحدود
الشماليه وحائل والشرقيه والقصيم والرياضه
ايضا وعسير وجازان والباحه تبدا من يوم
الاثنين الى يوم الخميس لكن في مجملها
بمشيئه الله ستكون متواصلنا
بالنسبه للرياض
ه متوسطه بمشيئه الله
شكرا جزيلا لك من جدا ضم الينا المتحدث
باسم المركز الوطني
للارصاد حسين القحطاني شكرا جزيلا لك
السعوديه اعلنت النيابه العامه عن ايقاف
خمسه اشخاص بتهمه غسل الاموال منهم
سعوديين واربعه الوافدين من جنسيات عربيه
حيث كشفت التحقيقات عن قيامهم بجمع
الاموال واداعها في حسابات ذكيه لكي اننا
تجاريه وتحويلها الى خارج السعوديه وصدر
الحكم القضائي بادانتهم والحكم عليهم
بالسجن لمدد بلغت 20 عاما وغرامات ماليه
تصل الى 500 الف ريال بالاضافه لابعاد
الوافدين عن البلاد بعد انتهاء محكمياتهم
ومنع الكيانات التجاريه من مزاوله النشاط
التجاري بصفه دائمه
تستمر منافسات ونسخه السابعه من مهرجان
الملك عبد العزيز الى الابل في منطقه
الصياهد بالرياض المهرجان الذين انطلق تحت
شعار
حتى الان 22 شوطن
تنافسيا من اصلي 75 شوط وتستمر طوال 43
يوما المرجان يتضمن واشرطه ثقافيه السعودي
من الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه نواف
عزيز نواف مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض ماذا لديك اليوم
المهرجان الملك عبد العزيز للابل
مساء النور نايف بعد الاجواء الممطره خلال
الايام الماضيه اصبح مهرجان الملك عبد
العزيز للابل جاذب للكثيرين سواء لزياره
الفعاليات المتواجده في هذا المهرجان او
التنزه بالقرب من منطقه المهرجان في منطقه
الصياهد التي تعتبر منطقه بريه جاذبه
للكثيرين
للتنزه وايضا المهرجان الذي يتضمن فعاليات
ثقافيه واسواق تعرض منتجات شعبيه لها
علاقه بالمرور
والثقافه المرتبطه بالابل سنكون الان في
جوله من القريه التجاريه ضمن فعاليات
المهرجان ومعنا المتحدث الرسمي للمهرجان
محمد الحربي اهلا وسهلا سيد محمد في
البدايه ماذا اضاف المهرجان هذا العام وما
هو الجديد اول شيء امسي عليكم امسي على
الاخ نايف ومشاهد الرابعه بالتاكيد احنا
اليوم نتكلم عن النسخه السابعه المهرجان
معناته سب سبع نسخ هذه مزيد من تراكم
الخبرات في في تنظيم مثل هذه المسابقه
العالميه وهي الوحيده على مستوى العالم
بهذا الحجم بهذا الكبرى اليوم عندنا في
بعض الاشواط الاضافيه وبعض الانشطه
والفعاليات المتعدده المرتبطه في الابل
واسواق الابل اليوم يتكلم عن ايضا القطع
الفنيه التي يعمل عليها بعض الاسر وتنتجه
على مدار عام كامل وتباع في سوق هنا همم
في السوق الكبير هذه نموذج للقريه مصغر او
نموذج لمحلات التجاريه مصغره في هذا
الموقع لكن السوق الاكبر هو سوق الهنا ضخم
جدا ليقع على 15 كيلو متر ايضا الفعاليا
الرئيسيه نعتبرها هي الجاذبه وهي فعاليه
عروض الابل امام لجنه التحكيم في المنصه
الرئيسيه هناك ايضا همم الفرز المبدا
للابل وهو يجد حضور هناك مسيرات الابل
هناك مخيمات المملكه التي تحدث فيها
العديد من الفعاليات الثقافيه والتراثيه
المرتبطه بالمورود
اتفضل انشطه نعم شاهدنا خلال الايام
الماضيه زيارات في وفود دبلوماسيه سفراء
لدى السعوديه همم هذه الزيارات ونادي
الابل اذن الى ماذا تهدفوا من خلال همم
اطلاع السفراء والوفود الدبلوماسيه على
مهرجان الابل والفعاليات المصاحبه لهم
بالتاكيد هذا تعزيز هوياتنا وموروثنا
وتاريخنا المرتبط في الابل نحن نفخر يعني
نحن امه ذات حضاره وتاريخ خالد مع الابل
فاليوم احنا هذا تعزيز لهذا الموروث نقله
للعالم شكله همم الجميل الرائع قبل ايام
قليله سجل ايضا حذاء الابل او الهبال في
اللهجه المحليه الدارجه ضمن التراث
اللامادي في اليونسكو وهذا يعد فتح جديد
لهذا النشاط وباذن الله سيكون هناك مزيد
من الاحتفالات حول هذا هناك انشطه ثقافيه
وتراثيه ومرتبطه ايضا هناك تعاون مع مكتبه
الملك عبد العزيز في اقامه ندوات ثقافيه
مرتبطه في الابل وتاريخها وايضا همم هناك
مزيد من التعاون هيئه التراث في مجال همم
التراث وبعض النقوش حول الابل وتاريخها هل
هناك مشاركات دوليه من في المنافسات في
اشواط الابل بالطبع هناك شوط باسم شوط
المنظمه الدوليه للابل وهم مخصص للمشاركات
الدوليه مختلف الدول العالم في العام
الماضي كان هناك مشاركات من بعض الدول اذا
نتكلم عن امريكا او المكسيك او بعض الدول
هذا العام نتوقع ان شاء الله مزيد من
المشاركات حتى الان باب المشاركه لم يقبل
والتسجيل المتاخر لا يقفل الا قبل
المشاركه ب 72 ساعه تقريبا كل الشكر لك
استاذ محمد الحربي المتحدث الرسمي لمهرجان
الملك عبد العزيز الابل اذا نايف كما
شاهدت العديد من همم الانشطه هنا في
القريه التجاريه همم متاجر متعدده كل
الزوار يستطيعون الاطلاع على المزيد من
التفاصيل المتعلقه بالموروث السعودي
والتراث المرتبط
بالابل المهرجان لا زال مستمر متبقي ربما
همم نحو شهر او اكثر على المهرجان 45 يوم
يمكن لي الجميع زياره هذا المهرجان
والاستمتاع بتجربه مميزه من خلال هذا
المهرجان الذي ينظم في النسخه السابعه
والمنظمين هنا في المهرجان اكتسبوا خبره
كبيره حقيقه في تنظيم مهرجان الابل
رياض مراسل العربيه عزيز
[موسيقى]
من بين خمسه عشره ثمانيه
فوق الخيال بتصميمها باعياد السعوديه
ومطاعمها الخمس التي يحمل كلا منها فكره
لن تكون موجوده في الموسم الماضي
الحديقه مجرده يستمتع بجمالها الزائره حيث
تم تحويلها لقصه يعيش في تفاصيلها الزوار
في الفصل الثاني منذ افتتاحها ضمن مناطق
الموسم الرياض ده جروف الحديقه المتجدده
بالكامل دون تكرار للموسم الماضي للمطاعم
العالميه والمقاهي والمحلات السعوديه
[موسيقى]
فكره الفصل الثاني
في قصه جديده فكره جديده تتبع دروس الفصل
الاول
والتكمله هذه لازم يكون احداثها جديده
افكار جديده
المطاعم اللي موجوده جديده شامل
رغبه الزائرين بالمشي في مختلفه الرجاء
الهمت مصمميها بان تكون ذاكروفس اب
المنطقه التي يستريح بها الزوار
والاستمتاع بالشاي والقهوه السريعه
قاتل قوه عندنا انه الطبيعه الاجواء
الشتاء في مو كل واحد
يروح مطعم
فقررنا انه المنطقه اللي فيها الاشجار
ونغير البوتات اللي بمنطقه اللي كانت فاشل
الى قهاوي وفي سناب
تجربه من جهتين
عامله ايه
[موسيقى]
الاجواء والاستثنائيه امتعت رواده ذا
جروفس بالعروض الموسيقيه ويعيش تجربه
السفر للقطب الثلجي وغيرها الكثير من
الزوايا المفاجئه والجاذبه للزوار من
الرياض شهد متروك العربيه
مشاركه اكثر من 900 ريال من ضمن النسخه
الحاليه من معرض جده للكتاب
حياكم الله من جديد دشنت هيئه الادب
والنشر والترجمه السعوديه معرضه جدا
للكتاب وذلك ضمن مبادره معارض الكتاب احدى
مبادرات الاستراتيجيه للهيئه اشد المعرض
المستمر حتى يوم 17 من شهر ديسمبر الجاري
مشاركه اكثر من 900 دينار 20 محليه وعربيه
ودوليه بالاضافه الى اكثر من 100 فعاليه
تتنوع ما بين الجلسات الحواريه الامسيه
الشعريه وغيره من الفعاليات المصاحبه
يعني معرض جدا الدوليه للكتاب ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد الحميد عبد
الواحد مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في النشاط
الرابع من الرياض 3 سنوات انقطع فيها هذا
المعرض عاد فيها مره اخرى الى عروس البحر
الاحمر كيف هي الاجواء في المعرض الذي
اختلف منذ نسخه السابقه وحتى اليوم عبد
الواحد
يعني يتوافد الناس الى المعرض باستمرار
هنا في يعني سوبر دوم حيث
يعني يتوسط هذا الموقع 900 دينار نشر كما
ذكرت واكثر من 400 جناح ما عرف فيه هناك
همم اضافه الى كل هذا اكثر من 100 من
الفعاليات الثقافيه المستمره التي اعلنت
عنها هيئه الادب والنشر والترجمه عبر
الجدول المنشور هذه الفعاليات نايف
الحقيقه انا مختلفه بعض الشيعه المعارض
السابقه حيث انها تحتوي وتناقش موضوعات
مختلفه على سبيل المثال في الايام الاولى
من المعرض كانت هناك جلسات همم حواريه
تناقش الرقمي اضافه الى المؤتمرين الاثنين
همم ضمن همم معرض جده للكتاب مؤتمر النشره
الرقمي ومؤتمر الخيال العلمي همم من خلال
استضافه شخصيات بارزه ومختصه في هذين
الموضوعين اضافه لذلك نايف همم الفعاليات
الثقافيه ال- ال- يعني مستمره نحن هنا
ننتصف الموقع كما تشاهد نايف يعني في
ساعات الاولى من استقبال الزوار لمعرض جده
للكتاب حيث يعني يتم اا التوافد همم دور
النشر همم يعني واضافه الى ذلك هناك همم
اعداد من الانشطه يعني نتحدث عن منطقه
لمشاهده ومتابعه مباريات كاس العالم اضافه
الى يعني الجلسات التي استضافت عبد الواحد
ممثلين ويعني مخرجي
لانه في شخصيات بارده كثير بصراحه في معرض
جده هذا العام حضره في ورش همم او ايضا
جلسات حواريه وغيره همم من هي هذه
الشخصيات التي حضرت من سيحضر ايضا كذلك ما
الذي تم نقاشه معهم اذا كان هذا معرض جدا
للكتاب يستطيع سيرين او مؤلفين او غيره ما
الذي يجري من احاديث
طبعا الجلسات الثقافيه والامسيات والندوات
الحواريه يعني الاعتياديه موجوده ولكن
اضافه الى ذلك هناك جلسات كانت يعني على
سبيل المثال كانت هناك جلسه همم يعني
تتحدث عن العمل همم المسلسل الشهير جيم
اوف ثرونز وبالتالي تم استضافه شخصيات
مثلت في هذا المسلسل كانت هناك جلسه اخرى
تتحدث عن العمل الاخر سترينجرز همم اضافه
الى يعني جلسه اليوم تتحدث عن الفيلم
السعودي همم شمس المعارف همم اضافه الى
ال- ال- المحتويات المتعلقه بالنشر الرقمي
وكذلك نشر الذاتي كل هذه الموضوعات تتم
مناقشتها في معرض الكتاب من خلال المسارح
المخصصه هناك اكثر من ثلاث مسارح موجوده
ومتوزعه تتم فيها النقاشات باستمرار هناك
كذلك جناح الطفل نايف الذي يشارك في يعني
كل من هو مهتم من يعني المؤسسات المتعلقه
والتي تقدم محتواها للاطفال همم نايف طبعا
نحن همم اليوم تعرف همم ما زال التوافق
مستمر لكن الايام اللي فاتت تحديدا
الثلاثه الايام الاولى بحكم انه كان نهايه
اسبوع كان التوافق اكبر ما زال الوقت مبكر
الساعه 4:00 يعني ما زال الناس يتوافدون
هنا باستمرار اضافه الى نقطه مهمه جدا
المكان واسع جدا وبالتالي هناك انسيابيه
كبيره في الحركه وفي الدخول والخروج من
هذا المكان اشكرك جزيلا شكرا على كل هذه
المعلومات تفاصيل الارقام من معرض جده
الدولي للكتاب مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد
احمد شكرا جزيلا عبد الواحد
تتواصلوا فعاليات مهرجان واحد الاحسائي في
سيتي مواقع تاريخيه ابرزها فعاليات عين
نجم التي تحتضن العديد من العروض الفنيه
والثقافيه وعروض الخيل كما تشهد مشاركه 25
حرفيا وحرفيه يمثلون مختلف الحرف اليدويه
في الاحساء المزيد
[موسيقى]
25 حرفيا وحرفيا يسترجعون تاريخ الاحساء
القديمه هنا في عين الجمل مهرجان الاحساء
في مجالات النحت والخصيات وحياكه
والنحاسيات كذلك صناعه السجاد والفخار
والسد وغيرها من الحرف اليدويه انا لي
تقريبا 20 سنه في مجال النحت على الاخشاب
استخدم اللي هو جذوع الشجر واستالهم
الافكار من جذوع الشجر وتفرعات الشجر
واعرف من رده فعل الجمهور اعرف ان همم
المجسمات شيء عجيب عنده وعليه جدا ممتاز
يعني بشكل ما يتصور والزوار اقبال عليه
يعني بشكل كبير
علينا نحن بالذات الحرفيين التراثيين اكثر
[موسيقى]
فعاليه متنوعه تجذب مختلفه الفئات العمريه
من زوال الاحساء وتستهدف استقطاب السياحي
من مختلف الجنسيات تتضمن عروضا للخيل
وفعاليه فنيه وثقافيه مصاحبه القديمه
بين الفن وبين العراق وبين همم الفن
اليداوي الاحصاء
وابراز الهويه صراحه الوطنيه للمملكه بشكل
خاص يعني
[موسيقى]
مهرجان واحه الاحساء الذي تجري فعالياته
في سته مواقع تاريخيه استقطبت اكثر من
147,000 زائر من مختلف الجنسيات بمشاركه
نحو الستينا حرفيا وخمسين متطوع من
الجنسين كما ساهم المهرجان بتوظيف مئه
وسبعه واربعين شابا وشابه في وظائف مؤقته
من الاحساء اللغبي العربيه
[موسيقى]
اخاف موجات البرد برد لحيمر وسمي بهذا
نسبه الى نجم قلب العقرب الاحمر وهو برد
الوسم اي انه يحصل في موسم الوسم واشد
مواجهات البرد برد الجزيره
ويحصل في النصف الاخير من المربعانيه
اي انه يتاتى في النصف الاول من
المربعانيه وسمي جويريه بهذا لانه يجلد
الاوراق عن غصونها وجويد هذا هو اللي يفتح
باب الشتاء وتبدا تهب علينا الموجات
الشتويه بين ان واخر على فترات متقاربه
وجويريه يؤثر على الشجر ولذير يؤثر على
البشر خبري بهم يا عيد هبت جويرين واليوم
انا يا عيد بقران هادي يا عيد عيدا ورا
عيد عيد الضحايا وعيد صوم
العبادي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وطوال فتره الشتاء الفعلي ديسمبر ويناير
وفبراير يبدا المرتفع سيبيري يؤثر بشكل
مباشر على روسيا وشرق اوروبا وشمال العراق
وشمال تركيا وبلاد الشام ويبني الثلوج
عليهم وتتعسر الحياه ويؤثر بشكل غير مباشر
على بردانه الخليج برياح شماليه بارده بين
ان واخر غدرا ولينا عنه ما يدفي اللبس برد
الشمال وناطحينه
غصب عني هنا كم الدبس تنام يا دراع يا
شيخط ما يشبه
[موسيقى]
تختيم الرابع زي عناوينها
وزير الطاقه السعوديه يقولوا ان التطورات
العالميه اثبتت صحه قرار مجموعه اوبيك
بلاس
الاقتصاد السعودي ينمو بنحويه 9% خلال
الربع الثالث محققا افضل اداء الربعين له
منذ 13 عاما
متحدث الارصاد السعوديه يحذر من حاله
نظريه من متوسطه الى غزيره على محافظه جده
ارتداء من مسائل اليوم
النيابه العامه في السعوديه تعلن عن صدور
احكام بالسجن العشرين عاما ضد خمسه متامن
بغسل الاموال
العربيه تتجول في منطقه يذاكروفس ترصد
تجربه الزائرين في منطقه المطاعم الفاخره
شكرا لكم
مزيد من الاخبار والمعلومات نهايه الرابعه
اعود والقاكم يوم غدا في رعايه الله
[موسيقى]